[Narration over soft music] In 1932, the United
States Public Health Service began a study of
the effects of untreated syphilison
black men in Macon County, Alabama.
Participants’ informed consent was not collected.
The study initially involved 600 black men – 399
with syphilis, 201 who did not have the disease.
Researchers told the men they were being treated
for “bad blood,” a local term used to describe
several ailments, including syphilis, anemia, and
fatigue. In exchange for taking part in the study,
the men received free medical exams,
free meals, and burial insurance.
Four decades later, on July 25, 1972,
Associated Press reporter Jean Heller broke
news about the study, prompting the U.S.
Department of Health, Education, and Welfare,
to appoint an ad hoc panel to investigate.
In October 1972, the panel advised stopping
the study, and a month later the study was ended.
The panel concluded in their final report that
the previous research on African Americans
with syphilis was “ethically unjustified.”
At the study's conclusion, only 74 of
the original 600 men were still alive.
Forty of their wives had been infected and 19 of
their children were born with congenital syphilis.
The Advisory Panel’s investigation led to
compensation for the victims of the research
and new protocols for the ethical
treatment of human subjects of research.
Voluntary informed consent for research subjects
became the new standard, and an explicit
requirement for government-funded research.
In 1997, President Clinton issued a formal
Presidential apology for
the Tuskegee Syphilis Study.
During its investigation, the panel collected
a broad variety of historical documents and
other papers. In 1973, a copy of the panel’s
working papers was deposited
in the NationalLibrary of Medicine, NLM, located on the
campus of the National Institutes of Health,
in Bethesda, Maryland. Through this research
and related public education made possible
by the unique collection held by the NLM, as
well as the National Archives, we acknowledge
the participants in the Tuskegee study and the
injustices they and their families suffered.
We also acknowledge the work of the Tuskegee
Syphilis Study Ad Hoc Advisory Panel to address
the unethical actions of the study which ushered
in new protections for the rights of patients,
and which continue to evolve with
new advances in science and medicine.
The NLM collects and preserves collections such as
that of the Tuskegee Study Ad Hoc Advisory Panel
to improve transparency in research, and to
ensure that lessons of the past inform the
present and future of biomedical research, health
care, public health, and healthy behavior.
[Music fades to silence]